[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to whoever left hello my name
is Ryan stickers buy our microphones and
hello to all you Ryan's out there I see
so many of you in the audience what a
name what a great name if somewhere
there's somebody who's maybe considering
having a child or about to have a child
who recently had a child who may haven't
named yet don't you want to name your
kid after an inside joke and the
Internet's 230 seventh most favorite
podcast we're just waiting heck we're
waiting for that one baby the one baby
to save us all baby Ryan the one true
Ryan hello John this is dear Hank and
John that's not how we start the pod pod
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nope that's how I wasn't ready I wasn't
ready okay right so guys alright we've
we've never done this live before I did
I did a live podcast once without Hank
it was great but it was all because of
Karen Haley and I had nothing to do with
the quality of the podcast clear now
I've got this Yahoo so we're gonna do
our best but please bear in mind we've
never done this live before we are gonna
be taking your questions but first we're
gonna take a few questions from the
listeners and then we'll get to some of
your questions hopefully I apologize in
advance for the fact that we're not
gonna answer almost all of your
questions okay
Hank go three two one bang it out hello
and welcome to dear Hank and John I was
weirdly over the top let's try it one
more time he's over the top John have
you listened to the pie you're right you
know I was actually listening to our
most recent podcast and that was the one
time I thought we weren't over the over
the top and I was like low energy yeah
all right all right last time last time
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Orr's I first think of a Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John we talk about death I
answer you a question give you dubious
advice and bring you all the way
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
today we are live at nerd God
nerdfighteria how you doing John I'm
doing so well the for one thing for the
first time in nine weeks there is good
news from AFC Wimbledon for another I
have to say that this first day at
nerdcon nerdfighteria this has been
really one of the best days of my life
just an incredible opportunity to hang
out with people who are the best like
who are the best people that objectively
the best and it's yeah it's not all the
time that you get to throw a party for
yourself and have a bunch of people show
up and it really does feel like we're
just in a room full of friends and
people who share our values and passions
and interests and it's just you know
when you grow up a nerd you dream that
something like this will happen and I
hope that everyone is having the same
kind of experience that we're having and
thank you so much for being here well
I'm also having a very good day John my
Mars news is bad it's bad Mars news John
so I'm glad that you you've got some
good news when you say bad do you mean
that it's good for the Internet's
leading Mars opponent Leon Maas it is
good for Leon Maas well do not cheer
good news for Leon Moss is good news for
me I know that you guys are out there
but I don't want to know that you're out
there I don't want to hear you out there
Hank follow up to the original bent re
whether the name of the podcast is dear
Hank and John or Dear John and Hank does
the moment we rename the podcast Dear
John and Hank come in 2028 or does it
come when it becomes truly announced
balls in 2028 John I think it come any
day now because it is not looking good
for humans on Mars by 2028 Hank I have
some Corrections well do you have a
short poem I don't okay well I I know
oh I know so here's the thing about the
short poem I am reading this incredible
book of poetry by a guy named Clint
Smith I think is his name he has 4 it's
so good there's one other person in the
audience is the book is called a
counting descent and it is so good and
it also has a number of short poems in
it and so I wanted to read one of those
poems but I haven't reached out to him
to get permission so I'll do that and
you'll get an incredible poem next week
I've got one John oh great it's a cold
place and they say it gets colder you're
bundled up now wait till you get older
but the meteor men beg to differ judging
by the hole in the satellite picture the
ice we skate is getting pretty thin oh
god the water is getting warm so you
might as well swim my worlds on fire how
about yours that's the way I like it and
I never get bored so that's what happens
when you forget for those who don't know
that was a poem called who's the don't
know
all-star by Smash Mouth all right we got
to get through some corrections really
quickly because we got so much stuff
wrong on a recent podcast first off we
got the population of the United Kingdom
wrong the backs will popular scene
United Kingdom is 1700 billion people we
also got the population of Canada wrong
it's there 14 Canadians so I apologized
everybody in Canada all 14 of you all
the listeners to the pod all wrote in to
correct us then we got several
Corrections about bacteria yeah as we
often do so first off babies are born
with gut microbes who knew but they are
we we got that from Francis and Francis
seems very knowledgeable on the topic
then we got several emails correcting us
about the the the microbes inside of cow
stomachs mmm-hmm and I have to say Hank
that 100% of the emails we got
correcting us about cow's stomach
microbes also corrected us about Star
Trek that is a thing there's a the the
Venn diagram is a circle so I'm just
gonna have to happen I'm gonna read you
one example there's several emails like
this one but this one is from James who
writes hello it was stated in the last
pod that it was bacteria in cows that
produce methane but it is not instead it
is the archaea in the guts of cows that
do this archaea while they appear to
look like bacteria under a microscope
are in fact as distantly related to
bacteria as you can get sharing a common
ancestor billions of years ago
pretty cool humans plants etc are a
subgroup of
archaea that once ate a bacterium and
kept it around as a power plant within
ourselves the mitochondria no bacteria
archaea are known to produce methane
these methanogens have been produced
have been proposed to be very ancient
they cannot stand any oxygen and methane
production would be a good way of
producing energy in times long ago or
some scientists think another possible
correction while the United Federation
of Planets was formed from the threat of
an external enemy the Romulan Star
Empire Earth was united through humanity
coming together to after many years of
war World War three with 600 million
casualties and the eugenics wars of the
1990s before them so that turned out
better than we thought
oh-hoh to get the 90s back when first
contact with the Vulcans was made after
those Wars fingers crossed that the
Vulcans make it here soon before World
War 3 of moss and moose James so there
you go thank you James for those two
Corrections we're wrong about Star Trek
we're wrong about the microbes inside of
cow guts I mean if this podcast provided
more dubious advice yes or dubious truth
mm-hmm dubious truth that's a good
that's a good say good name for a band
in the HIPAA Curren 21st century hey one
other thing wait what in the previous
podcast Hank said that street lights
were boring and then we got this
beautiful email about street lights that
is too long for me to read because like
anything when you pay attention to
something when you when you are
attentive and pay close attention to it
it becomes beautiful and interesting and
it turns out that street lights are no
exception in this regard we got a
beautiful email from a land surveyor
who's been doing that work for 23 years
about streetlights we're gonna post it
on the patreon at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John where you can see it even
if you're not a patron although you are
welcome to become one it only costs a
dollar or a month and you get
essentially nothing all right John
we got a question oh thanks any patreon
patrons out there in the audience hey
thank you guys thank you that's pretty
that's pretty great we
use that money to run scishow and crash
course we'll be honest that's actually
entire what we use all of it for well a
little bit goes to Nick for his non
scishow time or non crash course time
but anyway this question is from Glenn
who asks dear Hank and John quick
question now that we can grow meat in
labs can vegetarians eat hamburgers is
lab-grown meat vegan or is this also a
problem for vegans science has blurred
the lines for me I'm not even a
vegetarian well I don't know why you
care then Glenn how do they cope he's
got a concern for his own sake but for
the for the vegetarian sake and he says
trolls and bridges Glenn what do you
think John you're out you guys is my
question you John just got like
eighty-five miles from the mic I don't
know it's happening I'm moving away from
the question oh you don't want it you
just don't want any piece of this one
well you guys yeah well the thing is it
depends like it depends on why you're
doing it being a vegetarian there are
lots of good reasons to be a vegetarian
but I would I would say that like the
original cells that the lab-grown meat
is made from came from an animal they
might not have come from an animal that
had to die but for a vegan that doesn't
matter it has to like it's just anything
that that like influences like says like
you are an animal for my sake and I'm
gonna take your stuff so that I can
survive when I don't even need that
stuff then like lab-grown me it probably
doesn't make sense also probably to your
average vegan just sounds terrible
because of how it probably sounds
terrible to also your average human it's
kind of like hmm I get that and why this
might be better but also I however want
it I want it so bad somebody get me some
lab-grown Bologna I'm gonna put that
with some mustard on some white bread
and be a happy happy man
I'm not complicated so please send Hank
378 lab-grown hamburger patties
you will be a sponsor while we're on
that topic I just want to say a quick
thank you to nerdfighter
IRA who sent in Ari I literally turned
his name around in my head while we're
on the topic I just want to say a quick
thank you to nerdfighter Ari who sent in
378 dear Hank and John keychains I took
two of them Hank took one and we're
selling the rest liar
what I didn't take one you know I
reserved one for you I am I reserved one
for you we're selling the rest at the
dftba.com booth here at nerdcon
nerdfighteria to raise money for the
foundation to decrease worldsuck so
thank you Ari
also if you spell your name backwards
it's IRA and it anagrams to air Hank we
have another question this question
comes from Jordan who writes Dear John
and Hank I am a newly born nerdfighter
let's just pause mhm and thank Jordan
for coming out of the womb able to type
it's extraordinary
I have a three and a half year old she's
hopeless at typing oh now I feel like a
failure as a parent Jordan thank you I'm
a newly born nerdfighter and last night
at dinner an interesting question was
posed is a person who grows cucumbers
and makes them into pickles a cucumber
farmer or a pickle farmer
please answer is this is causing
distress in my family Jordan
wait now the sign-off no longer a fetus
Jordan
sorry it's no memento mori' I felt that
I could skip it okay I want to give
people credit for their sign up all
right like the people are taking it
seriously first of all I also like that
Jordan has taken the sort of cosmic
perspective of time and said hey look it
was not long ago it was very recently
that a person who is in their 90s was I
was in the womb like it's time and we
experience it quite slowly for how how
quickly it passes geologically and
universally what are you talking about
well I'm assuming that Jordan is now
like six months old because of Jordan
report by newly-born he means like 17
yeah cuz like in the scheme of geologic
time right he's just been born yes right
okay that's a great point second yes we
oh we are we are all newborns it's true
we're all just a bunch of babies trying
to make our way in this dark and broken
world
you guys give that one to Neil deGrasse
Tyson so you can tweet it for me
and secondly I think Europe I think you
are a cucumber farmer yeah who makes
pickles who makes pickles yeah I agree
you princess pickles cucumbers are your
produce if somebody asks you at a party
what you do you say I make pickles but
if like somebody asks you who you are
you are a cucumber farmer you know like
if you want to take it all the way down
like yeah all right I'm glad we took
that question seriously oh my god it's
burning oh my god it's burning for those
of you at home don't forget Dear John
and Hank writes Lane I am in the 11th
grade and I am being forced to take
chemistry this year I was a straight-a
student before this but now for the
first time in my life I'm faced with the
prospect of failing a class I feel like
my world will fall apart if I do that my
parents will hate me I'll never get into
a good college and I'll end up living
under a bridge how do I ease this
anxiety and get a bit get better at a
subject I hate with all my being memento
mori' Lane well you don't have to just
go live under a bridge no here's the
thing Lane you're freaking out about
something that like most things that you
freaked out about when you zoom out and
think about geologic time are irrelevant
because your life doesn't have like
geologic significance
you're just future oil lane so like and
by the way you know how that happens
chemistry it's true it's weird to think
about having geologic impact because
humans do humans have become the largest
impact upon the geology of the earth in
the last 50 years no in our cabal we we
reroute rivers we turn mountains into
holes yeah we eliminate the trees from
the landscape which completely changes
how erosion happens it's like it's
shocking cuz like of course when I once
saw a paper it was a test and the
question on the chest it was geology
class and said what is the greatest
force in the world and the person wrote
love when the teacher was obviously
looking for water because the
hydrological cycle has a huge impact of
course in this don't you think gravity's
the greatest force in the world
yeah gravity gravity also pulls the
water downward which without without
gravity there would be no hydrological
cycle but but John but if humans have
the greatest impact on the world as I
believe they do now yeah isn't it love
that made the human in the first place
kind of love it's kind of love right
yeah it's true though we are killing it
in terms of actually answering questions
no geology and also answering questions
here's the thing about chemistry don't
fail like so just get that get that
c-minus get it right where you need to
be you're still gonna go to college it's
gonna be okay there's lots of colleges
that don't care if you got a c-minus in
chemistry I I remember my first hey
there's good advice I think it is I
think it's great absolutely yeah just
don't fail it's okay like it's even okay
if probably okay I mean as long as you
can get that diploma Lane and you can
get out of high school and you still
believe in yourself and your own worth
as a human would yeah I think like one
of the big problems with grades but
obviously it's complicated I will say
that I like my first
chemistry class in college I freaked and
I did very badly
in like the first semester of chemistry
and I majored in biochemistry so
obviously like that wasn't going to go
and I like it was so terrifying to and I
was and it was really the fear that was
that was the reason like I couldn't get
the information in because I was so
freaked out about it and it took time
and like thought and like think like
trying to find other ways of learning it
that weren't just my teacher that were
other like the book and the and and the
internet to find ways to to get it into
my head and eventually it all sort of
like fell into place and and stopped the
other thing stopped being this
terrifying thing that was blocking me
from from enjoying it sometimes you just
have to keep going until it starts to
click in yeah and sometimes right before
it starts to click in is when it feels
completely hopeless and you think I will
never understand this I am the worst
chemistry student ever and then you
start to it starts to click in but you
do have to seek out other ways of
learning my suspicions Lane given that
you've done well in your other classes
is that maybe the approach that's being
taken to chemistry is not the approach
that's going to be most helpful to you
and so that probably means you're gonna
have to seek out other approaches I
recommend crash course chemistry but
there are also other ways we got another
one
it's from Amy who asks dear Hank and
John I've been doing very well at school
lately but to achieve all these good
grades I feel like very fake and almost
as if I don't deserve them and I'm
stealing somebody else's work it's like
I take my knowledge from some obscure
source and then make it sound smarter
and there's my grade does this happen to
you too when you upload things online
and answer questions am I just being
weird I've never done this before so
please excuse me if I say something
unusual Thanks also is it rude to email
is Twitter better I'm freaking out
best wishes Amy I mean there's an email
address Amy its Hank and John at
gmail.com and it's for this specific
purpose yeah first off I just want to
say in terms of doing that correctly Amy
it was great yeah perfect when I could
hardly have been better I love the
exclamation point after your best wishes
yeah I love that you included your name
the only thing I disagree with is that
euro dear Hank and John which seems like
you could have done that a little bit
better but on the whole I would say this
is an A+ email you even got all the
punctuation correctly inside of your
parentheticals this a phenomenal well
I'm gonna post this on the patreon as an
example of a top-class email so you got
that going for you secondly Hank it
seems to me that the process Amy is
describing is called learning weight so
somebody tells me something and then
like I under like I understand it and
then I say it back in my own words
because I've understood it well and then
people are like oh yeah you you get that
and they learning then they give you an
a on a test or paper good job that's you
did school you did school right I mean I
think there's something there's
something else may be going on here
which is the maybe like the dawning
awareness that there's a big difference
between understanding what other people
have already figured out and
understanding something new yeah point
in my experience having essentially
never realized something that other
people hadn't are already realized
before me you can go a long way without
ever figuring out anything new oh yeah
you'd never figure out anything no I've
literally never had a new idea yeah
brother a 2.0 was entirely stolen from
Zay Frank yeah I was like what if we
didn't say Frank but there was two of us
yeah that's not really maybe a slight
innovation yeah maybe I slightly tweaked
the formula to add a second person so
that I would only have to make half as
many videos yeah every single book I've
written I mean my critics will be happy
to tell you how derivative they are are
you guys do you guys could keep going
but trust me I've thought a lot about
this and I've never thought about
anything new so Amy you are crushing it
and I mean I cannot say enough about the
grammar of this email even in the even
in the parts where the grammar is poor
it's obviously intentional which I love
so Amy just keep going this is great
we've got another question from Jamie Jo
who writes Dear John and Hank I grew up
with a number of cartoons and children's
books that all contain some instance of
a character traipsing idyllically
through a field illuminated by fireflies
my question where are all the fireflies
I grew up in Washington State and now go
to school in southern Utah and there
aren't fireflies in either of these
places do I have to go somewhere
specific to find fireflies are they only
native to very small portions of land in
North America warm thoughts and warm
regards Jamie Jo all right I'm just
gonna ask for a show of yelling if you
well no no not location that's too soon
just do you have fire if you have
fireflies please yell now okay all right
and if you do not have fireflies please
yell now different voices but still a
lot yeah I would say that according to
my scientific study Jamie Jo
there are fireflies in approximately 60%
of earth oh man we gotta get that
peer-reviewed to be sure but I think
that's on well John this podcast is
brought to you by fireflies they're just
trying to find someone to love fireflies
there they're just not there there and
of course today's podcast is brought to
you by every koala ever
[Applause]
every koala ever my longtime sponsor of
dear Hank and John podcast additionally
is brought to you by 36 year old newborn
humans like me I haven't been here very
long
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by the song all-star from Smash
Mouth the song all-star from Smash Mouth
overplayed never never deliver three
hundred and seventy eight of them to my
p o-- box please know that is just
that's asking that's asking for it Hank
I mean that's Oh God I on yeah I think
it's time that I think it's time to put
the papers down we're gonna take some
questions from from our beloved
listeners I think I think that the lines
are the lion is sufficiently long so no
longer get in line I'm sorry it's your
birthday
oh wait what's your name alright
everyone's just quickly sing happy
birthday to Emily just also who else's
birthday is it I mean when there's
thirty five hundred people in a room
okay listen if it is your birthday stand
up we're about to sing happy birthday to
you everybody whose did your birthday
stand up don't lie we'll know
are you sure alright there sure all
right everybody ready up there come with
people at the top okay
they're up there in the corner okay one
two three happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday everybody today is your
birthday as you're listening to this
happy birthday to you as well if it is a
book the day before or the day after
stop trying to horn in on other people's
birthdays right all right so much less
special all right we have a we're gonna
take our first question from over here
yeah hi hello I have always struggled
with dedicating to things that I've
wanted to do yeah and my mom has quoted
me as saying that I want to be really
good at things without being bad at them
first mm-hmm how do I deal with that you
know the Phi snowboarded for for a you
know four times and one thing I noticed
about snowboarding is that not only that
I hate being bad at it but all the
people on the mountain also hated me
being bad at it right and I was like I
don't know you guys were you born with
like like slick slidin down a mountain
on with like a wood strap to your feet
in like your knees locked together and
this thing that's definitely gonna kill
you cuz I like did you never not know
how to do this and so that's one thing
is I feel like like we should all be
more forgiving of each other sucking at
stuff because like you don't start out
great and then additionally it's really
good if you can try it like first I
think you have to be forgiving with
yourself so that you can enjoy being bad
and if you like if you can find a way to
enjoy being bad then it doesn't matter
whether you're good or not so if you
can't sing if you're like me and you're
really just not a great singer when I
sing in the shower I love singing and it
doesn't matter that I'm bad at it
because I love doing it you have to find
for lack of a better term like the love
of the game whatever the game is that
you're playing you've got to find that
thing that makes you want to keep
singing in the shower
even if you're not great and then
sometimes not in the case of my singing
but sometimes you'll get better yeah
over there that was his other left your
left your it's true actually great point
hanket's everyone else is left you were
being very empathetic hello hi my name
is Ryan hi Ryan
it's like a a meeting my name is
actually Tori disappointing I'm
disappointed too yeah way my parents
yeah I do um anyway two days before this
I was dumped I'm sorry
and um anyway we met online we had
everything in common and I really really
liked her and she just said she didn't
feel this spark what is the spark
I mean if you well I got your answer
from the audience I think which is maybe
a bit of BS I feel like John's back way
away from the mic despite the fact that
he is among us the expert in being
dumped well I'm good I know I know a lot
about how to be dumped I don't know a
lot about the spark I mean you just have
to you have to trust someone when they
say that and it's hard to hear but you
have to let them have their life you
know and you have to let them have their
feelings it is not a reflection on you
although I'm sure that right now it
feels like it is but it does not mean
that you're not worthy of love or that
you're not a good person like I don't
think that human beings deserve much of
what they get good or bad but I
definitely think that we deserve to love
and to be loved and you are loved and
you will be loved in your life and this
is a moment when you feel probably
distant from that but it's it's still
really deeply true like you're a
valuable person and you're loved and you
will continue to be loved in your life
and I hope that's some comfort but you
can't yeah you can't make other people
feel stuff as much as you maybe want to
I'm sorry though it really sucks back to
the middle hello miss Brian
unfortunately there's a bow closed you
know you can go to a courthouse and get
that be chopped right off that's one
choice anyways my question isn't
actually from me it's from my friend
Caitlin and she is trying to decide
whether to focus on biology or English
and yeah your two professions and majors
she was wondering if you could speak to
that
get yourself a self that can do both
yeah I mean I well I write like I think
you're gonna do more than one thing in
your life like we always weasel out of
this question and so you're gonna watch
us do it again but there's this idea
like especially when you're young
because you are forced to pick a major
or a field of study and it's hard to
pick both I mean you can double major in
biology and English and I know people
some of my friends from college did it
one of whom is now a very successful
doctor who is also a very good writer
this is possible but you're gonna do
more than one thing in your life you
know so it's it's good to know about
both like ultimately I think biology and
English aren't they both trying to
understand what we're doing and how we
got here it's just different approaches
to the same like big questions in a lot
of cases so I don't yeah i'm weaseling
yeah definitely weasel weasel weasel
weasel weasel weasel weasel weasel
weasel make your own decision
yeah the only other thing I'd say to
Caitlin is I'm gonna flip this Cup
and if it lands like that that's that's
that's English and if it lands like this
which I think is slightly more likely
based on my knowledge of physics that's
biology because I think it's probably on
average slightly better to study biology
so here we go
really where do you think either of
those things are going to happen weasel
weasel weasel just got landed on its
side she's gonna have to make her own
choice unfortunately hello lefties hi so
I'm so happy that Brian went ahead it
makes my name is Briana which also kind
of has Ryan and gosh
I mean we're getting so close getting
really close and by the way the first
person who says the name is Ryan is
definitely gonna be lying anyway hi
Briana Fionna its Brianna Brianna Oh bye
Bri because even my loved ones call me
Brianna sorry
it's sorry okay you're not the first
okay um so my question is that
so I'm 19 and I have one younger sister
who is 15 I love her and we are very
close but I also very much want to
murder her most of the time so my
question is are there any particular
issues or anything that you guys feel
that urge to murder each other over can
I stop you real quick and just ask a
follow-up question to your question yes
do you mean murder literally I mean I've
tried to hit her with things but I'm
older so my mom told me that's not
responsible I mean all right well don't
kill anybody don't kill your sister
great point Hank don't kill anybody
yeah yeah I'm sorry our advice is
dubious but was it was it more of a
question about our yeah that was the
question but I just wanted I wanted to
check in real quick on the murder
situation I mean have we punched each
other I've punched you yeah I mean we
were not in a while I mean Hank and I
had a pretty intense rivalry when we
were kids you know because I was like
the same size but three years like less
mature and younger and right and looking
up to him yeah so I could beat him up
but I was very very like less
cognitively mature I mean I think like
for me the critical moment came when I
started respecting Hank and thinking of
him as a really interesting person which
was probably around the time that I was
like 16 or 17 and I recognized that he
was a really like smart interesting guy
and after that you know a lot of it felt
like I was almost trying to like repair
our I felt like there was some repairs
that needed to be done in our
relationship but to be honest we were
not really closed until Brotherhood 2.0
I mean that's yeah why we did it because
we would talk on the phone maybe like
once every year once every two years
like AOL instant message sometimes when
there was something important gone but
not even that often yeah not like weekly
or anything and I I just admire it was
kind of like I admired Hank from afar I
was like what a cool person who's
technically in my nuclear family and so
when I was thinking about oh I would be
great to do a collaborative video blog
that would be like lonely girl 15 meets
the show would say Frank because it
really was just those two ideas and I
thought it you know it would be cool
like it went what a great opportunity
that might be to get close to Hank again
and since then since January 1st 2007
like we've never had a big fight right
no I mean like that yeah we we have
dealt with I'm better I don't think
we've shouted at each other no yeah I
mean when we have shattered at each
it's been about this ain't like it's
been in agreement right there's nothing
been shouting in the same room where
we're just really worked up but we're on
the same page right yeah we're you know
really shouting so someone else who's
not they're mad but we're mad in the
same direction
not this way there's times when like
Hank has been like super annoyed with me
I remember one time at the first VidCon
I said why are you looking at me and I
was like what do you mean want and he
was like put your eyes away it was a
stressful moment but it was just
stressful and I wasn't helping you know
I was like Hank there's a problem and
he's like I'm aware there's a problem
and I was like but there is a problem
and he was like I know about the problem
and I was like thought I was told to
come tell you that there is a problem
and I don't know how to solve it and
then I murdered him no then eventually
the Gregory Brothers got their video
working and then they as it happened the
weird thing about that story is that in
that moment we were so tense like more
stressed out than we've been almost
probably since then except for a few
occasions and we were thinking like this
VidCon thing that's you know is gonna
fail and this is the moment where it's
truly gonna fail and then once the video
started working the Gregory Brothers
performed an actually and literally
sacred version of their song double
rainbow that transported all of us out
of the basement of the Hyatt Regency
Century Plaza into some like ethereal
land that only like Beauty can take you
to and it all worked out better than
expected not really answering your
question but thank you that was lovely
and everybody loves Yosemite bear and
going back to the middle hello hi my
name is Stephanie alright and I want to
start by thanking you both for
everything you do thank you Stephanie
thank you
you don't know everything I do reminds
me of a line from James Joyce someone
once walked up to him on the street and
said may I shake the hand that that
wrote Ulysses and he said no it's done a
lot of other things he was accused
complicated man just question in the
room that puts us in a tight spot
Stephanie I mean you're asking us to
basically pit the two greatest fandoms
in the world right now against each
other no answer I can only bring it to
you guys next reminds me of that time
that John asked Barack Obama to name his
child rock obama was like no i will not
do that yeah yeah I might pull a
lin-manuel Miranda on there so I'm like
if women well Miranda won't answer the
question there's no way in hell I'm
gonna answer the question because my
answer is literally whatever again
Manuel Miranda said high-quality
answered John thank you thanks for the
question sorry oh my god we are so good
at weaseling bring us more we should run
for office
No thank you but no I honestly I don't
know if that applause is a compliment
yeah yes hello my name is Glen sadly
it's not Ryan my brother's name is Ryan
if that counts for any that's great
congratulations to him yeah and my issue
is my girlfriend is vehemently against
the idea of me going into space she
thinks it's very dangerous
I understood yes I had this experience
as well when I was first dating my
current wife you have a dubious advice
of how to convince her that I will
probably not explode and die you know I
have a I actually have a literal friend
who may go to space who is married and
has children and and I have I know some
other people who've been to space and
it's not it's not an insignificant thing
for the family like it is a dangerous
job yeah no I mean I I don't I think
you're on the wrong side of this one
well I wouldn't go that early I wouldn't
necessarily but I do I understand I
think the you know take that concern
seriously and and my friend is like it
was a long conversation about like and
also like as he got closer to that dream
it became more of like oh we actually
have to talk about this and not in the
jokey way kind of thing so it's not
necessarily something like a bridge you
have to cross right now a number of a
number of life choices that you don't
make early in a relationship yeah I mean
that's I that's maybe what I'd say is
wait at the conversation seriously until
you're you know confident that this is
well many of you are I don't know but -
you're confident that this is a lifelong
thing yeah but I mean I would never cuz
what happened to me as I was like I want
to go to Mars like that's one of my
goals in life and Kathryn was like I you
know like we're not gonna get married so
what'swhat's the concern I don't care
you go to Mars like we we've been dating
for three weeks and then it turned out I
don't want to go to Mars because like I
throw up on like I get nauseous in
elevators so
Mars is not the place for me he spars
the place for anyone really yes okay
yeah all right
get over yourself John back to the
meadow so I'm Ben hi so my question is
you guys have been doing this for 10
years so 10 years ago where did you guys
think you would be and 10 years from now
where do you think you will be yeah what
about you where do you think you'll be I
had that I never I'm not like a future
thinker I have to be honest with you
yeah I mean certainly 10 years ago I
didn't think I'd be making YouTube
videos in 10 years like I thought
YouTube was gonna you know pass through
the world the way that most things do
and I certainly never I mean yeah it was
unimaginable like the Makai I look back
I look back at where like what I was
doing 10 years ago I was living in New
York I was I would just published an
abundance of katherines which had been
this like colossal commercial failure
frankly and you know I was trying to
write another book and and I was making
videos with my brother that at the time
10 years ago you know between 400 and
500 people were watching each video and
it felt great I mean that's that the
weird thing is like it felt like we had
a really like we were beginning to form
a really strong community that was
starting to do really cool stuff like it
was almost exactly 10 years ago that I
got this infection behind my eye orbital
cellulitis and that was really the first
nerdfighter project was Hank asked
people to send in pictures of themselves
with stuff on their head and we had like
400 viewers and we got like 350 pictures
and I was like it it's happened like
where you know we have this amazing
community of viewers and we're gonna be
able to do lots of cool stuff together
and I basically still feel that way like
that feeling hasn't really changed much
and I just kind of just want to have
that feeling in 10 years
and I don't really I hope that there's
still a bunch of people but if it's just
like four or five hundred of us but it's
four or five hundred of us who care
enough to send in a picture then that
would be awesome
keep doing it with me all right don't
think I have a choice
yeah that's the best yes ha ha ha you
can't really really can't go off on your
own I've locked you in I don't want to I
mean I really like collaborating with
you it's gone and weird and like you're
a super ass shut up don't know I don't
mean I was about to say a bunch of
negative things about Hank but then you
interrupted me with your all's what else
am i John you just like you don't you
have a different set of incentives from
every other person I know like I am a
normal person who is motivated by money
and ego and power and success and you
have no interest in any of that stuff
and it's so cool to be your brother
because you pull me in all kinds of
weird directions that you can only get
pulled in if you genuinely do not
experience those incentives the way most
people do that's very nice huh that's
very nice thank you I just
yeah I'm pulled in those directions as
well I'm also just pulled in like toward
weird I really like weird I know my
favorite people are people who just want
to do weird stuff yeah like I just love
it like especially when the weird stuff
is in some ways like generous are kind
to an audience I was just thinking about
how like it's almost like it feels wrong
in some ways to think that you can be
like silly and dumb and absurd and at
the same time really authentic and
caring and thoughtful like those things
don't feel like they're - two things
that could should be able to be pushed
together but that's the those are the
things I like to push together when they
are it's amazing like harrying the
Potters it's amazing like when those
stuff when that stump it's like nuclear
yeah all right Hank we got we yet we
have like a few more minutes to answer
questions so let's get through as many
as we can hello hi my name is Ryan
spells ug Oh Ryan girl perfect great me
and my girlfriend were an ax tripped
traveling and then we got stuck in men's
traffic and there was no way I had to
bathroom mmm there so I decided to like
been in Paper Towns yeah
improvise yeah and my question is we had
this debate what's the proper way to
dump the content that was well hopefully
you've got did you have a screw tap was
like Gatorade bottle was like an open
can it was like a McDonald's okay great
that's very helpful thank you so is a
McDonald's Cup so what you do in that
situation do trow it on the road oh no
John has a price fill the cup and
everything away turning in an ER so you
go when you eventually come to a place
where you can go to a bathroom you go to
a bathroom you dump the urine into the
toilet and then you then you take the D
urine cup and you put it in the trash
but you put it in deep enough that
nobody will touch it by accident
that is like your responsibility yeah
like if you if there's like a piece of
pizza that gets thrown in there you
don't want it to land on the cup because
I might come along later and eat that
piece of pizza you need what you
probably want to do is you want to put a
couple of paper towels maybe over the D
you're in McDonald's right exactly like
what I do when I get a illicit corndog
on the way home from work and then I put
that in the trash and then a couple
paper towels over it so Katherine
doesn't know I had the corndog is that
yes that stick is still in there
hi my name is Lance and I was wondering
what goes into making a podcast like
beside behind the scenes like how does
how is well as you can see Lance who are
an incredibly professional operation we
upload the files to a Dropbox where Nick
then downloads them and then he does
something and then it comes out on
iTunes yeah we don't know what he does
we don't it's some kind of black magic
yeah we don't know much about how it
works but we're grateful every Monday it
comes out and I'm Mike ooh
we sound much better than we signed it
in real life good work Nick we're gonna
take one more question before on the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon it's
gonna be ready sorry sorry laughs I
don't have your question asks I'm so
sorry it's the worst I
hi my name is Jackie that's an honor um
so I get to set up a bit of my question
I used to be in a research master's and
basically the professor told me I
couldn't do it
and I basically said well to heck with
it I'm gonna prove you wrong and I did
it anyway but great that's awesome but I
guess the problem was that even though I
was eventually able to do it it kind of
destroyed my self-confidence so I'm in a
new degree now I'm starting to be a
genetic counselor but I get told a lot
from my supervisors a lot of good things
and all the bad things but not maybe a
lot about things but could you feel
critiques on both sides and I professor
told me a few weeks ago that she's
noticed I always like keep my head down
but I'm a good student and can be a good
genetic counselor but I always focus on
the bad that I get what is your dubious
advice of how can I learn to remember
the good things that come out of
feedback yeah I mean I so like like I
had like deal with people like managing
people a lot in my daily life now and
whenever I'm talking to them I'm trying
I'm trying to help them learn like
ideally they can learn something from me
and so if I only give them positive
feedback even if they're the best like
they're not growing and so I'm looking
for things to be like what aren't you
perfect at and like that is a very
important part of all of our
developments like I need to hear from
you guys when I mess up I need to hear
from John when I mess up I need to hear
from my employees when I mess up like
like when I'm not doing like if I cover
doing something better I want to know
that so it's it's more like it's less
about concentrating on the the good
things it's more about understanding
that the the criticisms that you're
getting are they're not saying that you
suck or that you you shouldn't be doing
this
they're saying like we could all be
better like there's no one like there's
no one who couldn't be better at the
thing that they're doing right like
here's the next step that's how I try to
think of it like okay what's the next
but you know what can I learn and do
better in the next book I will say like
negative comment
penetrate in a way positive comments
never can because you you know you
suspect that they are secretly true or
that it reveals the secret truth about
you which is that you are worthless or
whatever and that's that part isn't true
you know like like when when you're
hearing something negative and taking
that in as I am worthless or I am not up
to this or I am not good enough like
that part is not true you are good
enough you are up to this you do you
know you are capable of it and and you
can get there and and that's I try to
remind myself of that that like when I'm
turning feedback into a reflection on me
as a person and thinking that it makes
me a piece of trash as in in the
parlance of the internet like that's a
that's a mistake because no person is
and certainly not me and I I guess the
only thing I'd say on that front is like
when I get negative feedback I really
really try hard not to not to get
defensive but instead just to say okay
is is that right and if it's right can I
can I learn from it and get better at
what I love doing and hopefully that
turns it into something that's not so
biting and personal but instead is an
opportunity to you know focus like
figure out what you're gonna focus on in
your next few steps as you go toward the
goal that you will achieve alright Hank
let's face it nobody comes to this
podcast for dubious advice they come to
the podcast for two reasons and two
reasons only number one and by far the
most important is to find out the news
from AFC Wimbledon League Ones greatest
team not by quality of results but by
quality of something greater than
results and the other reason is to find
out the news from Mars two solar systems
the solar system second most important
planet and eighth most important by mass
maybe sixth fourth the planet
you got Jupiter Saturn one by mass is
the Sun of planet Earth
no you Neptune in Uranus are also debt
gas trance it doesn't matter John we
don't have enough time for you to figure
out the freaking order to the planets
the news from Mars as people trickle out
of the auditorium because no one cares
that's not true the vast majority of
people are still here there's like 2500
people here waiting on the edge of their
seats to find out what just happened on
a cold dead rock like minutes away from
us didn't even happen on the cold dead
rock it happened here on earth spacex
as you may remember from last year when
i announced this and decided that they
were going to go to mars they're gonna
send one of their dragon capsules to the
surface of mars and that was gonna
launch in 2018 that was a very ambitious
goal they have decided that they're not
going to meet that goal
getting the dragon capsule to the
surface of Mars in 2018 was really like
kind of the thing that needed to happen
for 2028 to be not like Oh ridiculously
ludicrous timeline for getting a human
to Mars but really oh is it was it's
really about locking it in for till 28
2028 with the dear Hank and John because
you're not gonna change the name on me
it's not gonna happen you're gonna fight
about this later it's fine
if we get if Ian musk himself says that
2027 is no longer a possible date if we
get if we go yeah how does it works
not how it works alright how it works I
mean okay alright okay okay alright
first off there are bunch of people who
weren't chanting and I know all those
people agree with me anyway but
regardless of those people's existence
or not SpaceX has decided that they're
going to be launching that mission in
2020 it takes about like two year launch
windows for for Mars exploration so you
basically only like
the planets only line up at the right
spot every two years so we're gonna have
to wait so hey but but but it's possible
that they will be able to make this a
better more useful cooler mission by
incorporating a sample return mission
that they wanted to do a little bit
later as the second mission to Mars so
maybe this will allow enough time to
develop that sample return so the first
mission will collect some samples from
the surface of Mars or that have been
previously collected by a rover and then
return those to earth to be studied by
real human hands which is almost like
going to Mars except bringing it to us
instead of Mars when Mars can come to us
so Hank it is not being a great 2017 for
AFC Wimbledon or some would argue more
generally
in fact since Christmas AFC Wimbledon
has won by my count no games no just the
one just the one beat Oxford United 2-1
on January 14th since October Hank AFC
Wimbledon until very recently had scored
no goals away from home and has had a
very tough January not least because of
our noted opponents waterlog to pitch
and frozen pitch both of whom we drew
against and then lost for nil the
Sheffield United had to fight backs down
one nil to to get one one draws earlier
in the month then la then lost a game in
the last second to Shrewsbury and then
we played our old friend Gillingham or
possibly Gillingham I still don't
remember and we drew that game 2-2 with
the last-minute equaliser so that was
good but there have been a lot of draws
and no wins and and we are we were
beginning to creep down the table to the
area where it gets very scary because if
you are one of the bottom four teams in
league one you do not get to play and
lead one next season you have to go play
in Ligue 2 which is the fourth tier of
English soccer because everything is
named very appropriately in England and
it was getting very nervous and I was
very anxious and I was refreshing
throughout this morning at nerdcon Hank
I was just thinking I'm having the best
day ever if only if only AFC Wimbledon
could find to go
and then in the 68th minute who should
score but the Messi for Montserrat the
the Carribean Christiano Ronaldo viol
Taylor scored a goal to put AFC
Wimbledon 1 nil up their opponents
Walsall Wallis sale nobody knows how to
say it they hit the they hit the post
they hit the inside of the post and in
the 90th minute but they did not score
AFC Wimbledon won the game ending 8
weeks 8 weeks of not winning and they
now find themselves
I wouldn't say comfortable but they find
themselves in 13th place on 43 points
Hank the magic number is 52 if we could
get 52 points we almost definitely stay
up we've got 13 games to get 9 points
that should be doable go sports gay
sports all right John what have we
learned today well Hank we learned that
is that an actual dog is a real dog in
here that's cool I'm sorry for stressing
your dog out oh those are now Odin
they're probably stressing each other
right now oh there's yeah there's
support dogs up here
what did we learn today Hank well that
was the question I asked you but you got
real distracted so I'm just gonna go
ahead and say that we learned that
street lights and their planning can be
beautiful and complex and wonderful and
you can learn that at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John way to get the
patreon in there for a second time today
Hank that's hard work of course we
learned that Hank wants 378 lab meat
patties and we also learned that if you
pee in a cup you pour the pee into the
toilet and then the cup goes in the
trash varied a little bit down and
lastly we learned that all of us in the
scheme of things are newly born even
that doggy thank you all so much for
being here that is ultimately what we
learned is that doing live dear Hank and
John works and it's real fun yeah
hopefully we'll get to do this again
thank you all for listening real quickly
I got it I got to do the I got to do the
credits you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com I think that our email
address yep I'm he I'm a John Green on
Twitter Hank is Hank green you used the
hashtag dear Hank and John our podcast
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
gibson victoria bon giorno is our head
of community and communications and our
music is by the great gunnarolla thank
you again for listening as we say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
thank you guys
don't leave
[Applause]
[Music]